FRANK: Danielle's sending
us out to a guy named Mark
in Wisconsin.
ROBBIE: It sounds like
this guy's got a lot of...
of tonnage.
50 years, man.
That's a long time.
FRANK: Wow.
Look at that Blatz sign.
ROBBIE: I know.
FRANK: Whoa!
ROBBIE: That thing's badass.
It says "Frank's"!
FRANK: "Frank's Drink Blatz"!
Jesus!
ROBBIE: Are you kidding me?!
If this pick's any good,
I'm gonna buy you a beer
at the end of the day.
FRANK: Oh, yeah!
FRANK: Here it is right there.
ROBBIE: Ah...
Yeah.
[rings doorbell]
MARK: Hi, there.
[laughs]
FRANK: I'm Frank.
How're you doing?
ROBBIE: Nice to see you.
Robbie.
MARK: Hi, yeah.
FRANK: It's Robbie.
You talk to Danielle
on the phone?
MARK: I did, yes.
FRANK: We hear you got
a lot of stuff.
MARK: Oh, do I ever.
MARK: I'm a photographer
and artist
and sundry other things.
[laughs]
MARK: Come on in here.
I'll show you this room.
I travel all over,
picked up things.
ROBBIE: Ho-oly cow!
MARK: When I first came in here
all this junk wasn't here.
And, uh, little by little
I changed it around
to what I've got here now.
MARK: I have too many things now
that I'm trying to get rid of.
I don't want to leave it
to my children and grandchildren
to have to dispose of it.
They don't know what
a lot of this stuff is.
FRANK: Right off the bat, I'm
seeing some nice stuff here.
There's books,
movie posters, folk art.
ROBBIE: I mean, there is-- you
have acquired so many things.
ROBBIE: The biggest
thing in the room
is this Japanese flag.
FRANK: It's huge.
MARK: Yeah, it was flying over
Okinawa and it's all made out of
linen and all stitched together.
FRANK: A flag this big
in this great a condition
is hard to find.
ROBBIE: Do you
want to sell this?
MARK: Well, you know,
it was given to me as a gift.
And I'd feel real bad
about selling it, I just...
MARK: I didn't feel I could
sell it to somebody else
because it was given to me.
FRANK: I seen this
gambling device.
I mean, it's just a kind of
way of gambling, you know.
You would put your money down
on something, bingo, anything.
ROBBIE: Pick a number.
MARK: I...
FRANK: 6...
10.
MARK: [laughs]
FRANK: Is this something that
you would consider selling?
I mean, we see a lot of these,
but I kind of...
I like the base and...
MARK: Again, another thing
that somebody gave to me,
came out of their attic.
I just-- I can picture
the person giving it to me
and the smile on their face.
Can't do that.
I just can't.
FRANK: Alright,
I can understand that.
MARK: It does strike me through
that a lot of these things
that people gave me
that were very valuable,
that I would feel bad
about then selling.
FRANK: Mark had a vast
array of different stuff,
but there were some items
I asked about today
that were given to him
by his friends.
I mean, it's one of those
things where sentimental value
exceeds retail value.
At the end of the day, we've
managed to buy some good stuff.
FRANK: I'm glad I don't have as
much square footage as you do.
Because I would be
just as packed.
ROBBIE: Yeah.
MARK: Yeah, it's a problem.
ROBBIE: Seriously, thank you.
It was a pleasure
meeting you.
FRANK: Thanks a lot.
ROBBIE: Alright.
[honks horn]
FRANK: See you, Mark!
MARK: Bye, now.
FRANK: Thanks, buddy!